[Music]
point guard for the best handle you ever
saw God sham god damn god damn guy I've
never seen anybody with hands like this
his impact on today I think a lot of
these kids owe him a couple of dinners
[Music]
a god damn God's hype and oh is in the
lead hand it's one of the best handles
has ever touched a basketball today's
NBA is the Golden Age of the point guard
and in every Arsenal is a weapon that
most elite ball handlers utilize a
crossover moon created by God Shambo
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
different a lot of times you see a
crossover with side to side the ball
handler always had control to the ball
but with the sham guide is almost like
you exposing the ball more than usual
it's almost like breaking case of
emergency crossover that movie is like
very very dangerous to me because you
use it in the right situation it could
be one of those like game-changing moves
where you just hit somebody with a sham
god and then the crowd will go crazy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the kids call sham God known simply as
the sham God the crossover dribble is
modern art in motion used on countless
hardwoods all over the world I usually
use it when I know the person can't
guard me because this is easy
but you know he's gonna reach for he's
gonna reach for the throw out and then
when you snatch it it's just gonna look
crazy
I've definitely caught a few people on a
sham God or two I remember one in
Seattle I've just got a burner which
Jamal Crawford I hit the big with one
that I finish with my left hand I like
the craze behind the guy in God but I
like the I like the actual combination
of mood that's could possibly lead to a
sham guy so if you hit somebody with a
combination then you hit him with a sham
God move I feel like I get more
excitement out of that Brooklyn born
Harlem rage God sham guard grew up on
the playgrounds of New York City in the
1980s at an early age his future handles
were inspired by a legend I was in
elementary school and tiny Archibald was
my gym teacher and he always told me one
thing is like long as you learn how to
dribble you always be worth it to a team
I used to use one pound ankle weights
and put it on my wrist and then after
that everything else is just like
creativity and just reaction when I
first seen him play in a park not even
organized
I knew this kids especially handled
because it's always so long and when he
crosses it's almost a roll so for you to
try to steal it from him when he's
crossing over and his groove or whatever
the case may be you're gonna hurt your
fingers because your fingers are gonna
be on the ground a lot of people can
dribble the ball but very few can
control the ball he would put the ball
out in front of you and he had this
remarkable crossover it was like
mind-boggling you know
quick it was my coach bill hey bruh the
icing what I wanted to be in four years
and that's all I wanted to be McDonald's
all-americans it passes that he could
make off to pick a little whip in point
we did a lot of picking room you know
and him and Ron Artest Shamgar flirt at
LaSalle Academy earning an invitation to
the McDonald's all-american game in 1995
the roster included seven future NBA
awesome Messiah with him Vince Carter
and Paul Pierce and Shareef abdur-rahim
with all these guys and everybody was
talking about the scam got moved
[Applause]
following the McDonald's all-american
game sham God met another future NBA
star Lower Merion High School prospect
Kobe Bryant the chance encounter led to
an important realization I was like who
is this kid like he's a nut he's just
shooting the ball all the time so
everybody that was at the camp it was
like man this guy think he's Michael
Jordan his father was like do you work
with him while he's dribbling at one
thing I enhanced with him is just
throwing to dribble lower star higher
come low
[Applause]
that was the first time I meet teaching
somebody something and I guess that's
the kind of the path I've been on like
my whole life Shamgar went on to play at
Providence where in 1997 he led the
friars to the Elite Eight and the Flyers
[Music]
[Applause]
guidance in their regional final matchup
against Arizona sham guards famous move
was seen nationwide it was a play where
I was on the right wing act like I was
going baseline not to to boil out and I
ran like five steps and pulled it back
with my left hand the n-c-double-a
tournament for me is like sweet-and-sour
story because it was the worst thing and
the best thing that ever happened to me
because up until that point I haven't
thought about the NBA entered the draft
then I got drafted about the Wizards
looking back I probably did it a little
bit differently it stayed one more year
he would have definitely been a
first-round choice and maybe a lot of
reap ick you know unfortunately he did
well I came in Biddy Ishak that king of
Oz well yeah oh he's great sinner then
the NBA was more of a system but now you
look at 2010 a team they want the point
guard to be to scorer the leader I was
caught in between the times I always
teased my moms like man you know you got
me 20 years too early NC double-a was
like my coming-out party and I don't
really feel I capitalized the most from
it and I think one more year would have
been suffice and story probably a little
bit different now
Shamgar played just one NBA season so he
took his career and made his patented
handles global
and you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and when I went to China my first year I
got MVP and then my second year I got
MVP with Yao Ming and I was voted the
most popular player over there after a
nearly decade-long career overseas
Shamgar returned to Providence in 2012
this time as a coach four years later he
was hired by the Dallas Mavericks as an
assistant where every game he witnesses
the impact he's had on today's league I
just think it opens up the game because
there's so many combinations you could
do off the move the move itself is so
wicked his wick is it's identifiable you
know it's his so you see ask the goddamn
guy and I've seen people and other
players over the years trying to imitate
it but nobody's making look like either
[Music]
I taught myself
[Music]
it's next to
oh yeah kick it up to the esophagus
accelerate it really talks it comes up
with a fabulous tilting
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a different way of crossover he
knows his own thing you know that's why
everybody knows what it is because it
was so different
it wasn't like to be kind of back or
between the legs was just a right to
left or left to right it was just sort
of a flashy different play the appeal
behind it in the craze behind the gosh
in God is awesome man that movies has
definitely been tailored you know over
the years and you see different guys
using it for four different finishes
cystic Ryze is really dope because not
even just artist is a former basketball
player when you get a defensive person
momentum going to my left let's say yeah
right all the way and you know you're
not about to go that way it's like this
way you bout to be a smoothie
it's incredibly now looking back on it
because we come from an area Samba
through them our area is filled with so
much hate we come from that generation
in that neighborhood to where they not
necessarily appreciate with Sherman's
born Gaza moved that way I'll live him
that move will be around forever you
know everybody comes up trying to do
that move that particular style is doing
something yeah I just think now I'm
getting the notoriety that I didn't get
that much when I was younger for putting
in all the workers and I just feel this
is the basketball gods repaying me
understand understand yeah the back the
core game is no more your whining on the
just coming
make the phone pick it out longer than a
night and if you did though who's right
I guess I'm gonna
[Music]
yeah